it's not the way the tennis world number
one had expected to enter australia to
defend his open title
rushed into a quarantine hotel in a van
surrounded by guards in protective
clothing
instead of being fully vaccinated novak
djokovic had secured a medical exemption
before leaving europe
but he was blocked by australia's border
force who said his visa didn't tally
with that medical exemption his coach
goran ivan nisovich was allowed through
but was stuck at the airport waiting and
writing
not the most usual trip down under
australia's prime minister went in front
of the cameras to confirm djokovic's
visa had been cancelled and he'd be
getting no special treatment
rules are rules
and there are no special cases it is not
appropriate for me to go into mr
jokovich's own medical history that
would not be a fair thing for us to do
that they are matters for him to discuss
in terms of his own medical history
but what i all i can say is that the
evidence for medical exemption that was
provided was found to be insufficient
almost all of the players and staff at
the australian open have been vaccinated
some have also been given exemptions
but the djokovic case has infuriated
people in the world's most locked down
city all of a sudden he's he's been
exempt and can play and i think it's an
absolute disgrace and i won't be
watching it
even the djokovic fans gathered outside
of melbourne airport say they think
pulling out is the only option
well
obviously
we are disappointed but that's something
we can't really
change
we have no influence
serbia's president has even waded in he
spoke to the world number one on the
phone and hit out at his treatment on
instagram promising to step in
i told novak that the whole of serbia is
with him and that our bodies are doing
everything to see that the harassment of
the world's best tennis player is
brought to an end immediately
in line with all norms of international
law serbia will fight for novak truth
and justice
djokovic launched an appeal that's been
heard today but the court in melbourne
has now adjourned until monday
as it stands his routine to australia is
blocked and his stance on vaccination
leaves him in this quarantine hotel
instead of defending his title shimane
freeman powell sky news